[Musica]
sento che qualcosa sta spingendo nella
pancia forse un ippopotamo
o forse re di francia con gam bastimento
che dall'argine si stacca
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa dentro che vorrebbe uscire
fuori forse prigionieri o forse sono
fiori forse son galline chiuse strettino
una sacca
[Musica]
sì
sento un movimento che si vole libero
forse sono onde che si tuffano nel mare
forse è un esercito glorioso quando
attacca
[Musica]
vabbè ciao ragazzi oggi recuperiamo
tutto il tempo che non ho fatto le live
questa settimana perché devo farle
lunedì e giovedì nei giovedì ho potuto
farle e quindi oggi faccio una live che
leva recuperare tutte e due
quindi cinque ore di live fini no verso
le 8 farò un po di pause perché è un po
lunga live di 5 ore quindi farò delle
pause e vabbè come state
tutto bene volevo fare l'affare ball boy
che sarebbe tipo un gioco che avevo
portato tempo fa che non mi ricordo più
quindi ho detto cavolo che se fighissimo
da fare in live quindi fare i ball boy
senza dubbio e poi magari verso la fine
ci buttiamo su su qualche cosa che non
ho ancora fatto bene che vorrei fare
tipo le domande e risposte c'è magari
vediamo quanto ci metto a fare ball boy
quando lo finisco facciamo a questione
dancer di cose sono ovviamente
raffreddato falso io sono ogni tanto non
sono raffreddato nella vita quindi
scusatemi è un po così si sente quello
che dico si sente cioè l'audio funziona
tutto proprio la prova prova se sia
giusto per curiosi novak a volte parla
non si sentano avanza fatemi aggiornare
qua che dite facciamo per ball boy avevo
giocato tipo 3 4 3 anni fa non mi
ricordo niente sarebbe veramente ora di
giocarlo è veramente figo
finisco questa che facciamo un question
and answer di cose persone va bene va
bene va bene io non non mi ricordo
niente di ball boy tra l'altro però la
gru
aspettatemi mette lo schermo
hola amici oh che bello ed è bello
quando li fai un qualche cosa che volevi
di fare da un sacco di tempo e
finalmente trovi il modo di farlo come
si vede così dovreste vedere tutti
teoricamente pre non sento niente
ok sentivo nulla come va l'audio
[Musica]
se come l'audio lo possa alzare un pelo
aspetta un attimo secondo me l'audio lo
posso alzare pro ok siete cavolo faccio
una roba leggere da un sacco di tempo
non vedo l'ora allora bar poi sarebbe
questo in italia non sarebbe ragazzo
lampada
vabbè cominciamo
non so altro non mi ricordo quanto ho
giocato io gli avevo finito ma non mi
ricordo niente non mi ha tenuto i
salvataggi bene così e tutto forma di
lampada il tuo gioco anche la luna e la
luna quella sì io amo il mio lavoro
amo il mio lavoro perché sembra un bong
il nonno il successo va bene mio nonno
mi stava raccontando delle cose andiamo
a dormire
questo è il fatto ciao ragazzi già tutti
nel frattempo che entrate vi ripeto sto
giocando a ball boy finirò sta roba qua
non so quanto durera penso lo finirò
tutto e poi faccio un po di domande e
risposte randomiche c corri live e la
faccio fino alle 8 e tenero comunque c'è
la finestra lampada tutta lampada come
mio nonno si era così e tormentato
mentre mi raccontava le robe ciao silvia
io posso toccare mio nonno
ok questa cosa che non me l'aspettavo
però va meglio staccato la dentiera
ciao non ho fatto in tempo a leggere
dopo mi compare leggo grazie mille
e niente io posso posso devo andare a
dormire andiamo a dormire spegne per gli
atv che mio nonno ha detto vai a dormire
andiamo a dormire veloci ma posso
guardare la tv ma che figo cavolo non mi
ricordo a lo gela dentiera bros ottenuto
è un oggetto proprio che spegne spegne
per andiamo a dormire che resta a casa o
prendiamo a dormì esce esci così esce
sul gioco incredibile vi ricorre il
power globe ma sono tutti oggetti che
possono tenermi alimentari o no questo
no debutta vai come si chiamava quel
gioco simile che avevo fatto quello del
serino che si muoveva cavolo non mi
riconosce più però era molto simile a
penna o a devo mettere la dentiera del
bicchiere prima di andare a tv spenta
questa roba qua è una specie di cane
cane bo un cane mi metto cosa che faccio
come si fa a mettere la dentiera lì è
l'unico mi dice di metterla nel
bicchiere ma non c'è un bicchiere la
metto qua perfetto solo proprio il
nipote provetto sono proprio belle
nipote
no non è the wardrobe era un'altra roba
grazie mille silvia era un altra roba
era asciutta e giù c'è il bravo bravi
sul cell
cavolo un sacco di tempo che non ci
gioco ora quello però è troppo e passo
troppo poco mi ricorderei le cose tipo
ball boy non mi ricordo niente
che figata
quello è un cane brutto con le ali
quindi con quale fisica vabbè che tanto
è un gioco un po strano quindi va bene
acciao rihanna scusami avevo capito di
chiamarsi arianna soldi io non ho capito
però cosa ci faccio bassi posso andare
dal mio che quindi ha prima parte l'ho
fatta
era per capire i do ma i comandi i
domande
quanto tempo è passato da lucian un
annetto
ma forse meno scherzi ma detto fatto
successo
a vecchi se ne frega 17 giu cell mentre
stava entrando un buco nero nella mia
stanza
va bene come fa era una madre bellissimo
io lo so io lo voglio lo voglio se se lo
vendono lo farà io compro quindi mi sono
svegliato che è successo a ho sentito
dei rumori mi sono svegliato buongiorno
anno il nonno ha urlato beck ha senso
che non abbia urlato effettivamente
fatemi vedere solo una cosa voglio
vedere quando uccello fatto perché non
mi ricordo più shell aspetta è passato
otto mesi otto mesi porca vacca come
vuole il tempo ragazzo va bene le scale
devo andare di là ma ci sono però ci
sarà un miliardo per a fare prima di
uscire dalla stanza sicuro
ecco io già non dormirei con degli
insetti della stanza però va bene
che schifo io non dormirei maicon ragno
così distanti sto muoio trova bene
questo
6 tenero però non l'ho capito il senso
cerchiamo cose
poi ci sono un miliardo di oggetti
mazzeo che ne so io le forbici
c'è una cosa qua lo scarafaggio
[Musica]
non so cosa solo che schifo a devo fare
creare la strada lo scarafaggio ok ok
prova che schifo regalo prendo del suo
ok ho preso lo scarafaggio quindi questa
è la cosa che sorprende
grazie mille silvia thank you so much
scopo prendo più oggetti possibili non
so cosa devo fare per ora ragazzi se
avete domande o robe ethernet lan e
tutte per la seconda parte della live
quando fini rosso jong wha che le
facciamo tanto oggi proprio live easy
tieni spero stai calma mi fanno schifo i
ragni gianni ti sto venendo incontro
topic
io li devo dare 3 insetti da mangiare
mazza o e gourmet questo ragno è il
ragno di cracco che quindi devo prendere
sola mosca che altro devo prendere la
mosca e il lombrico che non ho idea di
dove sia tra l'altro nell'armadio mi
posso staccare la testa non ricordavo
mai sta cosa
non c'è niente ok è lo negli anni dove
se la mosca e libera non so come
prenderla ci sarà un tutto in modo a con
la scopa forse può essere no sennò ora
gara temi la mano è se non so le cose
c'e nel senso poi vede chiedo mi date
una mano perché se non è sempre il
solito questa cosa la corrente
posso a folgorare la mosca posso
formulare la nostra mentre passa sulla
lampada aspetta un attimo però poi dove
sia lombrico quello è perché ci provo
devo usare il tempismo giusto a questo
non è il tempismo giusto
vai veloce veloce cioè sono riuscito a
farlo nel momento in cui non è affatto
niente la mostra perfetto ottimo c'era
chi era difficile sbagliare a
impegnandosi forse ci si riusciva io ci
sono riuscito tipo adesso che mi sono
messa l'orsacchiotto che cosa me ne
frega
vai vai folgorati ed abbiamo due non hai
idea di dove sia lombrico rega però
vabbè grazie serena thank you so much lo
so eccolo da questo altri semplice in
realtà non lo posso prenderla con la
scopa sono bravo rega nient'altro
mandarla via
sì penso che non ci siano oggetti che
posso lasciare indietro cioè della serie
se vado avanti perché ho fatto tutto no
e su steam sisto gioco e su steam
non me lo ricordo assolutamente per
quello deciso di farlo però è veramente
figo
che schifo i ragni mamma mia che schifo
bene non aveva senso questa cosa ma ok
posso aprire la porta
let's go
boh
questo è successo lì cos'è per quale
motivo che questa cosa
oh mio dio
vabbè il mio per lui ha avuto dei
problemi il mio peluche e è il tipo di
visitors per ok andiamo avanti penso
fosse facile primo livello
grazie silvia grazie ma non so
pronunciato nome grazie antonella
qualcuno mi spiega cosa sta succedendo
in questa cos'è questa succosa cosa
succede state tutti calmi cibo possa
aprire da perché no no è chiuso vabbè
diciamo come che si esce anche se
e geniale sito gioco veramente la porta
salve mi sa che in casa mia sono
successe cose pace della colla non solo
si chiami niente a ok per sfuggire al
tizio devo passare dal da lampadario a
lampadario ovvio non avevo dubbi e posso
chiamare il mio corpo qua sotto
tipo ah si mi stava già seguendo noi a
questa che è successo chiedo al chievo
il tizio che è arrivato a casa mia a
posso guardare fuori c'è un qualcuno
morto sull'albero una scheggia e c'è la
luna che è bellissima regal ci sembra un
clistere at
ciao silvia grazie mille ciao anche alto
dico valerio ciao gianluca bacio c'è una
faccia qua secondo avevo vista mai
fisico ming è porta a e b spec sa che
non avviene
anzi le brioche e che non ho ben capito
dove devo andare però sì ma ci sono cose
che che spuntano
ho trovato una scheggia che qualcosa mi
servirà al futuro non so cosa davanti
l'altro è bellissimo perchè sti cosi non
si cagano di striscio il mio corpo ma a
me sì vabbè si sente ragazzi che sono
raffreddato me lo schifo sul naso
veramente chiuso facendo ma era così
lunga la stanza per arrivare al ha per
un attimo pensavo di potermi controllare
il suo corpo qua però non penso di no
a cosa serve fare questa cosa spiega mi
ha sì posso what anno aspetta mettiti la
scheggia davanti posso mettermi la
scheggia a si dava ben sto male con la
falce e cosa faccio dove falciate a quel
tizio che però non è uscito a non posso
ancora muovermi va bene quanto andiamo
avanti che la porta è aperta aiutato
sciamu sciamu sciamu fuori fuori dalle
balle
ok no non possiamo uscire giusta allora
ne solo poi menare menalon menaye
perché non riesca a menarlo cosa c'è
devo scrostare lo fa come faccia muovere
il personaggio devo fare altro perché
non ho altro alimentari questo punto
interrogativo
a chi dice che cosa puoi fare
è una specie di inizio va bene ma niente
tore ma dove trovare qualcosa per
muovere tipo la chiave li chao l'avis in
guardaroba di cicciobello è stata
orribile ma mi sono infilato la roba nel
deretano cosa mi serve una gara da
aprire il
dall'altra parte ok è tutto un gioco
strano questo va va bene non fa niente
larghe è bellissimo è vero ho ragazzi i
giochi belli i giochi belli veramente
escono una volta ogni mille anni e
questo lo fu questo lo fu questo tofu
qua la chiave
giusto mag
adesso c'è la faccia di un tizio ci sono
delle pantofole e c'è dell'olio all'olio
per togliere la per come si dice in
italiano mannaia lubrificare ecco il
cavaliere bene raga e geniale c'è giu lo
studio è bellissimo
ormai lo so che mi piace a tutti ma io
aspettavo da una vita di rifarlo perché
aspettavo di dimenticarmi com'era e lo
riparte da comunque io sono in un
periodo di nostalgia quindi ogni tolto
riporto qualcosa che valuti giocavo
tempo fa un bel po un bel po intendo tra
qualche settimana porterò got simulator
assolutamente perché già lo mi ricordo
più nulla almeno il pri la prima mappa
se voglio rifarmi le cose che giocavo un
tempo quelle che non mi ricordo
assolutamente quindi le porte o senza
problemi senza dubbio l'anno aggiornato
se non lo so
tanto non mi ricordo niente quindi anche
fosse raga parlo come una trombetta oggi
vi giuro sono di un rough siamo sempre
raffreddato io
[Musica]
lubrificano cosa allora ei
321 ci ha messo neanche troppo secondo
me ci ho messo un sacco di tempo ai
tempi scusate il gioco di parole ma
quando lo feci secondo me ci ho messo
veramente un sacco di tempo
questa volta no l'alguer cosa stai
tratto cos'è mai che c'è è un mio amico
come come si chiamano michele per ora
simone grazie ti offri costruisci il mio
amico che mi ha consigliato la canzone
di apertura con la quale ho aperto
questa live che era la canzone della
cacca cosimo niente ho tagliato sta roba
e non ho ben capito cosa me ne fanno la
prendo la tengo la jolie lato la faccia
che fa e bellissima guardate lui vi
prego basta meraviglioso della mia
faccia tutti i giorni quando vedo le
persone nel conto gioco messa faccia
parte un sacco immagino io non è morto
ma poverino dai è morto il nonno
[Musica]
che tenero mi dispiace
il gioco tristissimo e quindi no ora che
sto malissimo
mi dispiace tantissimo vabbè nuova non è
morto da in un po essere morta per
isolare subito la dentiera non risolleva
dai
no ho preso tutta la boccia agli la
signora perso in faccia
svegliate credo si svegli spero funziona
spegnete svegliate era o no hai fatto
tutto il giro per rilanciarla dall'altra
parte lo vedi che sveglio
ciao nonno a posto
non è andata proprio come pensavo porca
vacca
beh ma giochi a forte sì forte che il
mio gioco preferito perché non giochi
dopo a di visita ecco the visitor non ci
gioco dopo perché lo voglio riportare
era bellissimo
e stato un video bellissimo comprato sul
canale lo rifarò
tra sempre nel periodo de'co simulator
quando li farò simulator
io ho un calendario dove mi segno tutti
i video segno anche quello ce l'ho
perché ma e quindi non è la mia era mio
nonno che è sparito era per non era mio
nonno non ho capito stanno cosa fare qua
a c'è un cassetto
schifo
io me ne faccio di stock assetto niente
però mi fa piacere che mi hai fatto
vedere un cassetto pieno di lombrichi da
vado
e giusto e bellissima sta roba che ti
puoi staccare la testa ha poi andati
sopra anno sono cascato che tutto il
lampadario va bene ma giustamente se no
la mia il mio corpo come ci arrivava da
su puoi usarlo come fune posso usarlo
come fu è bellissimo è bellissimo punto
bellissimo
no c'è un flashback ma dai mi fa ridere
troppo ragazzi lo voglio lo voglio come
fratello lo voi lo voglio
[Musica]
l'api bird eye un gioco il flashback ok
ha quindi è un flashback di quando era
al parco con mio nonno ciao nonno c'è
deduco che sia il mio nonno cia le rughe
solo far lanciare il bastone al cane
cane tra virgolette tra l'altro sono
troppo illuminato
[Musica]
forse sì
ok
mi sono però ciò il basket o butta
gliel'ho nelle frasche buttalo bottiglie
l'anno a casa fa qualcosa tu tieniti un
regalo non lo posso dare al nonno cosa
volessi anche farlo andare a raccogliere
al cane avere un avevo capito c'è un
pozzo qua posso tirare sul pozzo anno
posso mettere le cose sul pozzo
ovviamente non oil sec quindi non ce
l'hai bellissimo sto gioco veramente non
smetterò mai di dirlo è troppo beh è una
reggio che forse prima di che ho fatto
ha la palla non il bastone e tirati la
palla allora nonno al cane
[Musica]
ma la ge ha tra l'altro voi mi sa che
non lo vedete di qua c'è un piccione c'è
un cielo e realtà
[Applauso]
boh primi appena fregato la palla cosa
devo fare
[Musica]
ho preso giustamente un cesto e melo
sono messo sotto il cappello
quindi niente l'obiettivo di sta ma poi
lanciare la palla al cane solo che sarà
fatta il cosa beh io devo di stare
l'uccello immagino per distrarlo c'è un
alveare che voi non vedete qua dietro
appena posso non posso spostare la
webcam comunque c'è un alveare dietro di
lui provassimo stanno così
[Musica]
ok niente
posso buttare qualcosa dentro l'albero
può essere eccolo
è uscita un ape perfetto l'ho presa solo
che devo fare in modo di distrarlo
perché sembra non riesca non c'è una
palla al cane giusto vedere allora sei
un pezzente
che fastidio ciao trek già angelo ciao
tantissimi soldi dal texas ci sono state
una volta ad austin sancho fa vedere no
meglio cosa sono perso tutto
metti il cesto nel tuo agio è vero e
posso capirla c'è il cesso nel pozzo
posso mettere grazie del consiglio
[Musica]
navigato sono curioso di sapere quanto
ci ho messo a fare ste parti quale i
video originali giustamente non
raccogliete perché un è un cesso
cosa può raccogliere
[Musica]
cosa ci devo fare questa roba aiuto
forse devo metterci qualcosa nel secchio
ci devo mettere qualcosa nel secchio
un'inversione penso devo dargli l'uovo e
ma ho capito quale uova non ce l'ho a
questo è vero cioè intra giovane la
prima a fare così allora diamogli l'uovo
al piccione però lo spaventi amo così ok
e poi gli diamo l'uovo direttamente
possiamo toccava telo eccolo è contento
ma perché c'è un occhio solo con te stai
lì adesso e dove lanciare la palla ma in
tutto questo il pozzo
ciao silvia prego
[Musica]
non ci credo veramente e finita nel
pozzo la palla porca vacca un'ora e
mezza allora adesso ho capito lo serve
il cesto lo porterai a non desti pillay
assolutamente sì ero indeciso se
portando come video normale o in live
penso in live molto probabilmente bajari
prima palla a devo usare anche il
tempismo giusto molto bene puoi
rilanciarli la non nel pozzo tipo ma da
un'altra parte
[Musica]
che gioco con un senso veramente che non
c'è
se fa tutto il pollo ma che minchia rivi
ha [ __ ] al pollo ragazzo gioca non lo
stesso è bellissimo e non ha senso non
c'è senso niente sembra di essere fatti
di lsd
che io sappia come ci si senta credo ci
si senta mille bello comunque simpatico
cosa ho appena visto nella mia vita
vediamo dove era arrivato nel primo
episodio per curiosità non aspetta
vediamo che succede adesso per lo vedo
figo però mai fleischman ci siamo
perfect vedo solo dove era arrivato alla
fine nel primo episodio per curiosità
per vedere se l'ho già superato ball boy
fa vj avevo fatto solo tre episodi sono
pochi
[Musica]
ero arrivato è arrivato qua incredibile
era arrivata esattamente in questo punto
va bene
la seconda parte i residenti volesse
lunedì come tutte le serie lunedì e
giovedì
intanto stata trattata da continuiamo
era arrivato in questo esatto punto
perfetto
perché hai fatto questa cosa
[Musica]
devo mangiare cose no
ok ma che schifo cosa appena visto che
schifo
veramente ammesso la manica che schifo
riga un po vabbè lasciamo perdere
[Musica]
cosa devo fare qua bagno dentro qua la
zampa
[Musica]
io più vado avanti più rigurgito eh
vabbè io mi farei una decina e fossi in
te proprio la madonna
cos'è sta roba da sto trovando nel frigo
c'è un altro nuovo perché sono fissati
con le uova il creato di visto gioco
usciamo o salve mag e c'è un tacchino
formato gigante porca vacca via via via
via via via via veloce veloce lo show
lacerato sono morto ma no sono morto
veramente che schifo fine anche un gioco
violento non è family friendly come
pensavo di caccia dentro frigo immagini
o mi caccia dentro il porco però del pro
porto è lo so finito si ha tra l'altro
questo qua potrebbe prendere questo come
testa
non mi ha preso è riuscire perfetto vai
veloce non solo fregato non so come apri
cosi tratto di fiammiferi e bueno forno
posso metterci le uova scommetti no
scherzavo
sì invece e lido a fuoco dopo che i
fornelli pro devi uscire perché il tipo
sta tornando
eh sì è sì facciamo dopo no non esci dal
gioco e sheila porca vacca nativo ci dà
la schermata proprio ok
[Musica]
sì
non so cosa ho preso ma torniamo
indietro proprio il tipo si prenda male
ma nel frigo non sono riuscito
e difficilissimo cavolo prefiggo anni fa
ripartire di qua ok
quindi quello fa un giro tutta questa
roba qua non lavora anche vi è pieno di
cose che non vedi il suo gioco
fighissimo vabbè niente diamo fuoco i
fornelli questo punto no se questa roba
qua dai poco ai fornelli dato eccolo
alla canna del gas
mamma mia che casino per dare fuoco alla
roba lì
sei sicuro adesso poi telefono con la
roma però secondo me il tipo mi maggio
in tempo zero
sto cucinare uova e ci esci non è ancora
arrivato lo zio eccolo
ok praticamente dovrei essere riuscito a
fuggire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
posso uscire io dalle cuffie lo sento
che alla mia destra quindi no
[Musica]
cioè quando lo si fa quando smetto di
sentirlo posso andare adesso lo sento
ancora quindi no
perfetto poi uscire poi ci riesci ok a
cosa è servita sta roba di cucinare le
uova ragazzi cioè è servito qualcosa
immagino o dove mentre anche questo a
due metri anche questo adesso siccome
non è ancora finito devo fare cose ma
non so cosa devo cucinare delle robe ma
non ho capito cosa devo prendere come
ingredienti cestino ma ke skifo la
ma perché prendi delle robe decenti e
poi cui ceva nel frigo non c'era niente
a parte le uova la ricetta dove la
ricetta dove la ricetta c'è una ricetta
mentre scritto c'e la ricetta ma non la
vedo coltello non ho capito cosa devo
fare con temporalmente c'è qualcosa
indietro lasciato luca stato vediamo se
passa prende con 34
no no sono uscito che pirla ha la
ricetta stava nel libro
a sori soldi non avevo capito va beh
intanto vediamo questo e poi cuocio
tutto però non ho capito perché devo
seguire st ricetta quindi devo andare al
libro mamma libero che intorno al tavolo
ragazzi a vedi che posso prendere un
coltello cori con un puledro torri
ho preso il conte proprio sempre faccio
a fossero tagliare un pezzo di hamburger
da 28 e tra l'altro che schifo ma perché
hanno fatto sta roba è orribile
posso
salta su e familiare lazio la ricetta
dovrebbe essere questa giusto allora la
ricetta torta e salsicce e farina 2 uova
3 salsicce e farina già cosa ci vorrà
essere
però la salsiccia dove la prendo
mi manca il coltello ma mi manca la
salsiccia capito scendi scendi entra 4
non so dove prenderà ce l'ha forse nel
deretano quella della salsiccia
che schifo sta roba rega devo tagliare
tagliare lui può essere o no forse devo
tagliare qualcosa che ci in frigo deve
riscattare qualcosa a esco prendi io
prendilo questo nobel james carr che
schifo eccole a sono salsicce sono vermi
va bene sempre meglio
niente niente adesso può aspettare che
lui ripassi di nuovo perché sarà un
casinò a gesù ma alla fine l'articolo 3
ma sapete che l'articolo 13 non so più
non ho più sentito niente quindi finché
non sentiamo nulla va bene
a il tacchino sarebbe il pollo che prima
ha preso il cane del flashback che però
è diventato gigante c'è niente c'è sta
roba che mi ha invaso casa e mi ha reso
gigante e io starò fas non l'ho capita
però vabbè uscire posso uscire si esce
prima sono uscito per sbagliare non esco
più uscirò che devo mettere sta roba qua
nella torta che schifo
[Musica]
allora così aumenta vai
ho fatto un casino per forza parte però
ci dovrei essere riuscito
la fai è fatta la torta eccola è una
torta felice anche lui è felice va bene
mi sa cosa me ne faccio a gliela faccio
mangiare a lui al nostro amico nuovo e
poi coperti la torta lo prenderebbe ok
che culo pensavo di morire tantissimo
invece non sono morto va bene o un
tacchino gigante che schifo lo sono
mangiato sul serio ragazzi e bellissimo
io lo amo lo amo e bellissimo punto
punto joe simon e giocare until dawn
sarà migliore bellissimo guardai
comunque al di là non l'ho mai fatto
lo farò
vediamo se lo faranno in live non lo so
grazie mille comunque grazie silvia ciao
teo ancora costi saluti madonna rega che
ben porta dei miei saluti
grazie mille però ammazzano che
esagerata chri chri chri grazie mille
devo devo capire un attimo cosa devo
perdere il problema geniale mettere i
tasti di uscita del gioco uguali quale
il quale dei due alta suscita ok settimo
quando fai quando combinazioni windows
ti chiede a nulla e a nulla
boh non so quale fare dei due comunque
cosa mi è servito farmi mangiare il
tizio alla fine non l'accesso a ecco c'è
chi lo ha preceduto di un millisecondo
stai cagando sotto immagino era un
tacchino enorme beverages cioè io mi
sono mangiato un tacchino di 8.000 kg
what quindi
ti prego da date melo se esiste da te
melo lo voglio che cosa ho pagato
e rist etico da un bel pezzo zio eri
veramente stitico sembra quello di una
città incantata
va beh probabilmente l'avevo detto anche
nel video originale il profumo ha lo
stordito ma come non puoi tirare l'acqua
immaginato a si è scaricato si è anche
incazzato devo ritirare cosa ragazzi
inquietantissimo è orribile madonna
l'ansia rea guarda guarda che gli si
avvicina dello specchio che ansia di
vivere orribile fare qua
[Applauso]
a conquistare più di tanto se non urla
va bene questa parte è molto difficile
la piccola ho paura proprio di questo
cosa che ti si ti sei anni ma se la
cacca nel cesso averi che la canzone
nell'attaccare in tema alla fine buona
cena a tutti stasera
guardate questa live prima di cenare per
carità è che lo fa è caduto il pomello
devo fare cose nel tempo che con la sua
vicina tipo tira la maniglia avendo
collegare i soldi ok la mani devo
prendere aiuto
datemi una mano per fare qua a devo
spegnere la e tutto sto casino per
spegnere la lav entra ok allora accesa
lamentano dello spento
no
amo latino la faccia dentro lì
bene adesso la faccia si è rotta ci sono
un coso brutto
e schivo ma vado a far incazzare più
volte in modo tale che poi mi faccia
cadere le cose dal soffitto giusto tra
cui c'è il tubo che mi serve ho capito
usa il profumo il profumo masinga sento
a posto prendi ok adesso mettilo nel
tubo c'è l'inventario e la mia il mio
posso uscire ancora devi cagare
l'inventario è il mio corpo
ecco riuscito ad entrare
ok ci ha messo un'ora e mezza a fare sta
roba però ok
[Applauso]
buon appetito a tutti buona cena
buonanno e buona vita
[Musica]
va beh
cos'è successo sono finito nel dentro il
cesso
ragazzi questa guerra avventura astrale
del creatore del gioco che si è fatto un
viaggio di paste pillole e acp però va
bene tutto
quando c'era ragazzi residenti volesse
lunedì e giovedì baron chiedete più
lunedì e giovedì tutte le serie lunedì
giovedì e ogni episodio faccio un sacco
di roba
quindi non è che 10 un e baghdad a
rilento nel primo finito tutta la cosa
di polizia che era lunghissima quindi
lunedì e giovedì esce residenti vivono
tranquilli e faccio tante cose così
tengo botta c'è non rimango indietro
rispetto agli altri capito io l'ho già
finito l'ho già recato tutto esce pian
piano
[Musica]
perché ci sono sti flashback che non
capisco ciao veronica grazie mille a io
sono il cane
sto male come sa e un flash back perché
sono annegato nel cesso c'è lo stesso
sto ancora pagando nel me nei meandri
del mio scarico e quindi niente mi
piacciono si flashbank ma la barra
lacoppola del nonno che sta sul bon ad
innaffiare l'albero che diventa una rapa
non avevo dubbi che un cane veramente
brutto questo però va beh entra là
dentro
eccola l'albero l'arma fiato ecco la
rapa prendi da rafa la rapa volante tra
l'altro rubate
un gioco per premi nobel e ragazzi ma io
posso interagire col mio nonno o col
pesce posso leccare l'acqua nello stagno
c'è una lavatrice
o edifici essa parte lo fa il latte
visto gioco posso anche non chiedervi
consiglio perché ogni volta che non so
fare qualcosa
porco demonio starà paschi posa io te lo
so eccola dai prendi la c6
ma forse non la devo prendere perché me
la facciano che mi ha fatto falso casino
ma le rape notai non so qualcosa clicca
qua
[Musica]
a devo farla mangiare a qualcuno all
a val bormino da lunedì le live dove
torneranno da lunedì a giovedì fises i
ragazzi non male la juve sono sempre
lunedì a giovedì solo salvo eccezioni
tipo oggi ok io spingere la rapa 18 ma
chissà se magna stanata non capito
savagna nessuno ha il pesce
ecco la top e scatenò pescato io ho solo
quello di pesce cioè prendi quello a non
forse la rana addirittura sai c'è ball
boy che sta tentando di prendere il
flash c'è solo quello che è successo
ciao zia cos'è cos'è ai cagato niente
[Musica]
non ho capito
non avete amici dopo lo
c'è un citofono
[Musica]
siete pazzi non mi hanno suonato al
citofono non è vero e non troppo bravo
[Musica]
lei
se non ho capito cosa devo fare qua
a devo riempire la rana ce ne volesse
una sola è uno che casino un pesce non
c'entro niente del solo dall'ara va bene
non far esplodere la rana nel momento
piscia dentro la piscia di nuovo dentro
l'albero non escono le rane piscia c
[Musica]
è un capitolo non piaccia più ragazzi
non mi piscia più personaggio questo è
successo appena mi pisciava pisciava
dentro l'albero non lo fa più normale e
non lo fa più guarda doveva fare pipì
nel buco dell'albero ma non la fa più ha
smesso a devo bere l'acqua ogni volta
che dichiara mi giustamente è un gioco e
realistico un po meno per tutto il resto
vai piscia
[Musica]
il gol
passò due immagino siano quattro in
totale c'è dovere piscia porca vacca sto
cartello che fastidio
[Musica]
una quarantina
[Applauso]
[Musica]
o no magnate la poi il bello che sta per
es
bellissimo perché sta per esplodere e
continua a mangiare che ho vinto cioè
non gliene frega niente che sta per
esplodere dice vabbè ma mangio solo che
dice o in sala magna della magna dal a
un savagna l'ultima non se l'è mangiata
forse non solo schiacciarlo
ripeto è un gioco per premi nobel questo
quindi cosa ci fa adesso cosa ci faccio
che abbiamo fatto per la rara
ho capito niente devo mettere un girino
what a mia persona
si poteva andare qua sotto
posso spostare un nome ma bova bell e
carla senso cosa sto facendo perché sto
spingendo un lombrico messo otto ore
però
[Musica]
no
quindi
[Musica]
non ho capito niente di quello che è
successo ma sai che tra tutte le cose
non ne ho capita una non ho capito nulla
il che è fantastico era già oakley bat
bacio alla mia criba così è successo per
la madonna
c'è un alligatore su un coccodrillo nel
mio cesso ottimo ami ami ha resuscitato
che faccio facendo vi è un anguilla
quindi quella sono nel mio accesso a
posso solo rotolare questo gioco è
fantastico non so se l'ho già detto nel
ve lo dico e fantastico
porca vacca a non devo farmi prendere
dai lombrichi
tutto normale ragazzo tutto idilliaco
ci ha fatto tutta la parte di prima per
far pescare ball boy wow comunque
geniale cioè non so che chi si sia per
linda non ha via via via via veloce
veloce ok no no aiuto
devo dribblare tutti i costi ok mi hanno
appena lasciato perdere ma lasciato
perdere
[Musica]
io raga non so che cosa ho attivato però
vabbè è veramente [ __ ] st parte perché
se non l'ho capito il perché dovrebbe
esserci un sottomarino nel mio accesso
però dettagli sembra il mio cane
versione gigante con un occhio di fuori
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
magna della magna dello lo fregato
subito sono bravissimi
[Musica]
ma cos'è oddio sono diventati pesce ma
no posso andare dove voglio
che figata ciao quindi adesso sono
ufficialmente immune ai lombrichi no
anche di sempre mi ammazzano
che figata fatto mi muovono con ritmo
compulsivo
aiuto aiuto si spaccano
ok che genialate incredibile sta roba
no stava pregando ritirati ritirati ok
dov'è che sto andando esattamente se sta
uscendo dai cro
amici aiuto
qua è un problema molto più grosso del
solito
ecco teoricamente dovrebbe essere a
posto teoricamente ci sono un miliardo
di lombrichi aiuto aiuto aiuto ce ne
sono un miliardo
non so come si chiama di tutti aiuto
armi già fatta trovata solo entrato in
un buco ma veramente fighissimo val voi
se va bene cos'è qua
ragazzi qui c'è un problema c'è un
problema di lombrichi
non so se ve ne siete accorti
[Musica]
quindi ho capito cosa sta per succedere
senza che sia per succedere 321 anguilla
a non è l'anguilla è una patata che mi
arrotato in faccia questo gioco è
veramente pulito
vorrei family ferendone almeno quello
cos'è sta roba qua quindi non aspetta
fammi capire quella roba l'ammazza c'è
giusto perché se ne sa che bisogna che
ci vado addosso m'ammazza aiuto aiuto
aiutami amico mio
aiutami amico mio non so cosa fare i
suoi lombrichi cosa devo fare cosa sta
succedendo cose sono successe troppe
cose insieme non ho capito niente però
c'è l'anguilla di sotto sono morto
sono morto e non si muove più ho pagato
il gioco sono morto nel mentre che ho
fulminato tutti quindi si è pagato il
gioco tecnicamente è giusto o deve
andare così
raga ho pagato il gioco potrei aver
pagato il gioco il che è incredibile
velocità pagare il gioco ora mi
riconosco veramente vito riavviarlo ma
non gli andò sembra prender di futurama
con in mezzo
vabbè ho pagato il gioco devono
ampliarlo wow
la cosa mi è successo a poche volte
nella vita in live mai penso addirittura
di aver pagato già speriamo li abbia
salvato la partita ma salva in
automatico sono dovevi farmi tutto va
bene sarebbe un po strano e bellissimo
peccato per il bug si è pagato che sfiga
sono riuscito sono riuscito a pagare il
gioco incredibile grazie veramente non
sono sono guarda io queste cose ci sto
veramente da dio che mi ha ripartito da
più avanti di prima quindi da quello
sbloccato la tipa insieme ha pagato
fantastico ma sarà una cosa a marzo
quindi
[Musica]
capitana scorsa vasto che questo avesse
innamorato della bombola il cambio della
bomba vuole una lumaca va bene tu stai
fermo io devo fare fuori questo qualche
un boss praticamente uno l'abbiamo già
fa anzi due l'abbiamo già fatta solo di
sa di vino c'è delfino perché siamo
prese topolino morto sono vivo non si sa
per quale miracolo però non capita
l'attimo dove dovrei andare dove la roma
dove la trova la lumaca di giudizio un
altro lavoro manca di giudizio
ha forse posso andarci dietro economica
minuta in faccia porco demonio aiuto non
ci sono roma che ha mentito
ho capito non c'è
sto cercando da un ora
se che non ho capito stava facendo della
lumaca ragazzi lo spiegate ma c'è un
piccolo di minecraft ma ci sono un sacco
di riferimenti sto gioco a caso di
barili quindi lo rende ubriaco
il copricapo tutto scemo
va bene adesso posso dargli una botta
che è successo ma che è così non mi
rotta in facciano esatto
non riesco a passare lo stesso
arcade voglio
[Musica]
beh allora se riuscite a passare uguale
dov'è la lumaca aiuto
che è l'unica parte da quando è iniziato
il gioco dove mi hanno appena bloccato
però non ho capito veramente dove il
tipo si è disgregato molto bene forse
devo
ama sta qua ma c'è un altro pezzo quando
l'avevo visto no che schifo rega sta
diventando veramente orribile la lumaca
quindi possa andare dal tipo familiare
la bomba
cos'è successo
[Musica]
come no alla vuoi pure sgusciata c'è
tutto potesse parlare né può sbirciare
la lumaca con l'anguilla la sguscio
chiaramente no scusami perfetto sta roba
non aveva sempre ok lumaca morta solo le
migliori prelibatezze da fa vigenti
carlo crack posso
grazie gentile adesso prendo la bomba e
la lancio al tiziano dall'altra parte
non di là ok sembra la mia sveglia la
mattina vai mò come devo farla esplodere
prima cosa devo fare esplodere col tasto
di sopra c'è il tasto per detto darla
sarà mica il tasto per donarla quello la
destra c'è un tastino qua a destra non
ho capito cosa sia questo quando
schiacciano ma non devo si ha certezza
che non lo so help me la devo ammettere
nell'occhio questa l'ho capita però poi
parlato di spedisce indietro fa solo
briaca reprima può essere a ecco
adesso dia possa lanciare visto poté
vedere un attimo ha trovato adesso
l'occhio alla forma della bomba perfetto
[Musica]
ma vado ha detto no alla bomba in tempo
in tempo dai veloce veloce credo che
debba fare in tempo giusto ma questo è
il tasto per detonare la bomba volo sta
diventando maschiaccia o per farci ho
messo una vita a noi lombrichi no però
ti prego cosa ridi ci sono i lombrichi è
difficilissimo li odio si lombrichi
a parte un casino faccio così ci sono
riuscito
gli otri platì tipo cristiano ronaldo
vai ciao quanto preso male nel nuotare a
gesù
è un altro flash back se io sono il cane
va bene allora questo gioco è bellissimo
c'è giuro mi piace tantissimo
meno male che mi sono ricordato che
esiste allora facciamo che porta anche
la carriera un musichetta carina per la
pausa faccio 5th basava da pisciare bere
e basta
e poi torno ok niente arrivo datemi
cinque minuti arrivo
[Musica]
terza
sì
[Musica]
lavorata
yahoo
beck
[Musica]
a me diverte un sacco vedere la esatto
quando ogni volta che torno da una pausa
c'è la gente che si sta fruttando in
faccia perché sto tipo in sei minuti
invece che 5 mi diverte un sacco sta
roba a caso che più o meno la stessa
intelligenza della gente mi che di
salutarmi
[Musica]
raga ma ripartiamo o no ho dovuto
mettere a posto anche la cucina perché
non lascia tutta la sua minchia e non ho
bevuto
lo sa bene
[Musica]
va bene ma va avanti quotidiano alan
wake l'avevo fatto quando tipo prima di
aprire il canale era finissimo è
veramente figo
ripartiamo credit e dovrei che ero
rimasto solo il nonno come no vabbè ci
metto ore a fare una cosa ma adesso sono
il nonno rega fermi cose che ha detto
gli chiede non ho capito ha detto ma
vabbè né avanti
kat sinapsi mettono veramente sei ore ad
andare da una parte all'altra veramente
mi fate fare il nonno che palle non è
vero non è vero pure si addormenta anche
a caso allora ga sto male sono ha senso
possono interagire con mio nipote ciao
nipote bravo nipote è stranissimo sarò e
cosa devo fare
in tutto questo casino ma ho dei poteri
io come no no no posso solo manganellare
le note c'è una pianta non è vero che si
poi non è vero che si addormenta mi
rifiuto di crederlo ci mette sei ora a
fare un metro dai cheppallle quanto ci
ha messo a toccare la pianta è niente da
non posso fare niente
c'è un rubinetto o cosa potrò fare ci
metto 6 ora farlo però almeno lo fa che
lo faccia chi è fastidio è orribile
scegliete un ora e mezzo nelle subito
niente altre cose che posso prendere
toccare fare c'è una penali che però
come ci arrivo
o
tensione incredibile successo qualcosa
ok cosa ride va bene
no vabbè ragazzo malissimo 20 giu basta
[Musica]
quindi devo innaffiare la pianta poi
parola se in una serra cos'è sta roba
qua sto innaffia anno devo riempire coso
madonna raga mi viene il latte alle
ginocchia ti prego dice al latte nel
bastone
no no non cccp tardi perché mi ricordo
deve fare ma non c'è
no ragazzi io c'è veramente mi taglio mi
taglio la voglia di vivere che alle o
dio mio
bravo ora mette a innaffia la pianta
vincerà
dai dai
in aria la usa i nati questo usa all
[Musica]
cavolo e proprio divertente ma non mi
ricordavo fosse così esilarante questa
cosa ciao pizzi incognito ovvero una
caccola
[Musica]
qualcuno mi spiega perchè io non ho
capito non ho capito nulla però va bene
io odio e ragni la dovete finire di
mettermi i ragni a gesù allora potevo
fare qua prendila ok ok
devo prendere il controllo del ragno
mamma mia quanto sono contento di tutto
questo mi sono addormentato e
mastrangelo viene qua devo prendere il
controllo del ragno quando erano è sotto
di me è chiaro come ci sono finito qua
che non mi ricordo più a dal tubo di
scarico sono uscito ok ma adesso sono
ragno
va bene che schifo lo avere quindi possa
andare sul tetto altro boss davvero ci
credo avanti boss ragazzi sono tutti va
bene a questo che la serva di primo
quindi se che ha detto che per niente io
sto rivivendo tutte le situazioni
prima e dopo che schifo al ragno raga mi
fa veramente schifo
vi giuro mi fa vomitare andiamo avanti
io li ho visti tutti anni
vabbè che devo fare
allora lascia che non ho capito ha forse
devo lasciare che colpisca le cose tipo
qua colpiscimi qui qui qui c'era il coso
maledizione colpiscimi di nuovo
cosa che deve colpire scusami deve
colpire una roba sulla ragnatela avevano
capito cosa tra le mille robe che ci
sono la vasca devo colpire qualcosa che
cosa a questo ok se si è questo quel
sicuro
vai vai sparami che bello che sei tra
l'altro la mente nessuno
forse devo far colpire proprio la
ragnatela di preciso capito tutto
knight e adesso me ne faccio di sta roba
qua devo toccare cosa sulla ragnatela
va bene non della can aiuto a devo farli
non sparare ok
vai vai che mira che c'ha mammamia
orribile ma all ac lo devo buttare sulla
base della pianta hai capito come sto
buco bucalo o devo trovare qualcosa per
bucarlo storicamente la sc allora cosa
trovo per v carlo prova a farlo senza le
soluzioni fermi
[Applauso]
ha il chiodo il chiodo chiamato
schiaccia chiodo incitò far cadere la la
la
questa roba di sopra giusto ma vice pari
a misurata sulla sparami giusto ma non è
un chiodo era un innaffiatoio come dove
chi se ne frega
usiamoli innaffiatoio ma come mi ha
sciolto non ho fatto in tempo a
schivarlo
ma cavolo marzo è difficile ho capito
tutto quello che ha detto
muoviti muoviti muoviti noi diventi
ragione veloce mamma mi ha fatto rotto
pure quella e giusto
no non è giusto devo bucare quella roba
lì e forse veramente dopo ha sparato al
cane sparami a è morto cade quindi
niente
ok non sono proprio bravo
non so capire cosa è capito vabbè di
niente
devo trovare qualcosa per bucare perché
non ne ho la più pallida idea
bene che le soluzioni erano alla va a
capirla lavandino giustamente what preso
vai ora teoricamente ci devo incastrare
nel lavandino con cecilia castelli nel
contenitore questo giusto perfetto farci
metto questo e poi lo innaffio guidato
non si squaglia l'innaffiatoio con
squagliano quagliarella imparato un
sacco su di sé la madonna che casino
[Musica]
prego di fido no che carini
manca solo il nonno ragazzi l'hanno
banca noi facciamo non ce la facciano
ridere c'è chi mette troppo di buon
umore il nonno è scors kursk
eh sì andiamo
[Musica]
salendo a salvare il nonno che belli e
quindi porca vacca sono beccati siamo
vivi siamo entrati entrambi nella
finestra per ora posto ma noi la madonna
via via via via veloci io posso decidere
se clicco sopra comando luiss e clicco
sotto comando come è giusto
ok quindi io di solito dopo mettevo fare
in modo che quello di sopra ci abbia la
luce sono si caga addosso capito ed
altro c'è un mostro ingiusto questo
chiaramente prendilo non ho capito come
deve rifare accendi
e giusto rifugiato
sta parte veramente un casino laga devo
prendere delle robe
state io comando il cane tranquillamente
cioè c'è un cubo di rubik c'è un lego
playmobil questo quali serve serviva
teoricamente
a nella scatola e fai natel freddy's di
te ho sbroccato coso ok con la scatola
veramente quello di file ater traces ma
sono io che l'isola luce quando sono qua
ha capito figata prendi cose non so cosa
servono
vabbè equa e fin qua ci siamo arrivati
non so come sono stato bravo quanto ria
dovresti prendere questo a fare qua se
riesci no che mi sembra troppo evidente
che debba prendere quello che c'è
proprio il cosa no mi ha fregato non
sapevo che potesse prendermi
[Musica]
era una donna che schifo no anche schifo
lui che schifo che ho soffiato il naso
io vabbè davanti no scusami scusami eh
bravo tra l'altro quello al mio corpo
non so se ve ne siete accorti
ragazzi è più difficile del previsto
molto semplice del previsto
ma poi andare a vedere cosa c'è dietro
la porta di far vedere cosa devo tirare
con gli affari sulla luce come dovrei
riuscirci scusami
a e quindi
chi deve attirare pian piano davanti ma
cosa fanno mi serve mi servono per
distrarre il coso siete scemi lega
guarda
ma lascia che il coso si pigli cosi va
bene se non si è preso i cosi che devo
fare io non se li è presi sempre solcare
non sta bene
non è esattamente quello che ho fatto
[Musica]
ma dai varco demonio porco morto draghi
è difficilissimo ho cliccato sul mostro
se non ve ne siete accordi non sta
andando magari l'inter prima su questi
no sai che non so come si fa sta parte
non ho idea a posso muovermi io quando
faccio così ok allora posto di atel e
figlia trio ok
sorry no ho capito ma amo posso andare
io che non c'è più lui che casino
se mi serve stare ma l'ho trovato a
metterla quale al generatore sicuro
anche se non ho capito cosa mi serve il
generatore inizia per sempre ok sto
adesso
amo posso aspirare le robe capito
aspetta
tanto quella fare occupato a mangiare
cose che posso fare ma superano non
abbaiare basta
ok evidentemente non devo faremo sfidati
devo mettere ok ho capito il nastro sul
cosa anche se non ho capito cosa ci devo
fare questo coso tappare il buco con lo
scotch a sori
non ho capito
ma no anni faccia tirare io ho capito no
entrare il tuo corpo direttamente
l'etica importante che tu sia felice
ora andiamo liberati perché c'è
l'immagine del cuore se di vado sul culo
ma non farlo ti prego non farlo ok
pensavo facesse tutt'altro
lei ha abbracciato perché tutto chiaro
andiamo avanti ma di tutto questo siamo
tornati in casa c'è il mio nonno qua il
mio obiettivo era sarebbe quello di
tornare in casa tecnicamente
eccolo ragazzi quello non è il nonno
ragazzo è quello non è il nonno ve lo
dico io non lo è
[Musica]
non è il nonno raga si vede un km dal km
che non è no
no ci spero tutti
la madonna è il mostro va china
quindi se non lo hai bevuto un po troppo
che lo fa c'è un chiodo schiaccia tanto
io non ho il mio corpo giustamente
allora quella 1 schiacciato la coda è
stato fatto tanta peccato che non era il
nonno ma l'hanno ancora vivo in tutto
questo non è morto da via c'è il corpo
iniqua sta dormendo
sono entrato dentro e una rapa nera
questa starò con una melanzana
[Musica]
che sta succedendo ragazzo sta
diventando veramente sitra ho rischiato
fortissimo di essere schiacciato ma non
lo sono
ok è la prima parte l'abbiamo fatto
questo è il il boss finale
potrebbe essere il boss finale ragazzi
sai che non lo so non ho la minima idea
strettoia kakà a sinistra io andrei a
sinistra così tanto perde
eccole qua le mie cacche ma devo
spegnere tutti i fuochi che schifo cos'è
niente mi hanno fatto fuori barco
demonio spezzatino
siamo sicuri che io debba andare a
sinistra dove non devono alla sinistra
[Applauso]
[Musica]
restano essere stretta essere devo
provare a farmi sparare addosso giusto
no non è vero
beh allora non andiamo a sinistra
andiamo a destra magari ho sbagliato io
strada giusto potrebbe essere
che schifo ragazzi so già che mi fa
venire il voltastomaco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che schifo la sorpresa è beh adesso sto
vomitando posso andare in giro
che figata in teoria quel vomito servì a
farmi passata roba chiaro chiaro è un po
mito a propulsione ma non c'era neanche
lo storico per usarla che schifo ragazza
romani fa veramente schifo perche e
giusto come ho fatto
ecco
ma riparte lo punto ho finalmente non so
che cosa ho fatto ma va bene quindi
[Musica]
ok il primo a fuoco andato ne mancano
altri due giusto che cosa sto facendo a
aiuto a 15 anche la fase esterna ok è
concediamoci concentrations
l'altro cosa devo fare esattamente
grazie dove recuperare il nonno grazie
mille di questa ok dopo solo schivare
vai vai schiaccia c'è il tasto per
aprire la porta nuova
va bene
saprò mai morto morto morto morto quanto
pare cosa schifo questa è la pubblicità
quella del concorso che quando ti brucia
lo stomaco
ecco quello che adesso me la sono anche
cavato al basta ghetto facendo se fate
bene attenzione di sopra di sopra di
sopra i polmoni spara
ok
non so bene cosa sto facendo
e giusto cioè sto facendo sta andando
alle parti giuste sono entrato in punti
alla pace il fuoco dimora
[Musica]
ok lo aspetto un altro sono stato
bravissimo
non so liga riuscito a capire come fatta
falsa roba l'ho fatto e basta
manca solo quello di mezzo gara
quell'altro che non son riuscito a fare
prima scriviamo che bello sto tizio
da allora devo resistere ma l'hanno
fatta benissimo stabat stavo sbatto sia
e la finale per forza ragazzi veramente
incasinata quindi per forza alla fine la
fine
allora la finale fatto
[Musica]
sì va beh no non ho capito se non ho
capito niente di questo
come devo passare scusami
[Musica]
quand'è che devo passare adesso raga non
sto capendo minuti ma è difficilissima
aiuto l'ultima un casino fermi fermi
[Musica]
forma col demonio morto difficilissimo
così vai no da il giorno anche il dito
che sfortuna beh è l'ultima è
difficilissimo ragazzi con studiata un
sacco l'ultima curva così adesso stai
qua per due giri anche quello dopo
[Musica]
adesso porca put ladra
l'ultima parte la difficilissimo ragazzi
veramente un casino sì ormai l'ho capito
era difficile da capire dal primo botto
così ok dai ma che sfiga all'inizio ne
che palle
devo stare fermo due volte negli stessi
punti ogni volta minchia tutte volte ma
con ha cannato
vabè ragazzuoli si va al finale che non
ho capito dove la sinistra la sinistra
cioè sinistra rispetto a dove dovevo
cadere prima quando c'è la cacca giusto
sai che non ho capito però forse video
far sparare la merda addosso la cacca
addosso sorry ho detto una cosa non
family friendly è giusto eh sì mi dovevo
fare incazzare
non ho capito stato non mi stupisce più
niente di sto gioco grasso succedendo
alla mia barriera a kakà che si sta
esaurendo
eccolo
[Applauso]
cos'è che ho fatto allo spenta
sventa no
sì l'ho spenta
berg e ce l'ho fatta l'ho battuto
c'è ancora l'ultima fase cioè di fare
[Musica]
eh no scusami dove tra l'altra volta
ma quante volte devo fare sta cosa qua
ragazzi nulla ma dai ci voglio morire
adesso voglio morire in questo momento
che culo porca vacca morta provato a
farla randomica ci stavo riuscendo in
una maniera incredibile
stavolta esattamente come prima e
pensavo di non morire un pirla
[Musica]
ok così
no per una volta che non ho fatto veloce
per una volta che sono stato fermo e non
l'ho fatto veloce prima tutte le ho
fatte veloci sono morto sempre per una
volta faccio il parsimonioso lo serve a
niente nella vita chiave consigli che vi
do co demonio
[Musica]
ieri
sorridono anche culo
ma cambia ogni si vede che non sono io
che sono non sono attento mi sembra che
stia cambiando ogni volta c'è prima non
si muovevano tutti e due
non è che non mi ricordo di quanto devo
andare avanti ok
beh va beh
[Musica]
adesso devo tirare avanti fortissimo no
ora tenuti davanti fortissimo ok ho
fatto la domanda c'è da portare il cuore
ci stanno ma perché priva lanciano i
fuochi non potevo passare chiaro questo
può fare lo toccarlo è una melanzana
ragazzi marcia direi allora schiaccia
crisi devole carli l'occhio a debole
card devo leccargli l'occhio senza farmi
leccare senza farmi sputare addosso bene
ragazzi è un gioco per questo gioco
qualo dalla prima rientrare ad harvard
prima di entrare ad harvard e vi fanno
fare il test di ammissione che è giocare
a ball boy e io ve lo dico
quand'è che io ho aperto la bocca quando
lui è sparato
facendone carni l'occhio e la cosa più
intelligente che ho visto il suo già fa
quando ho iniziato a coltivare tanto
questa cosa
sto leccando l'occhio ad una ad una
melanzana paranormale non so se è chiaro
ad una melanzana dub step pasta quanto
tempo mammamia rischiato guardo anche
qua
no come non mi ha colpito porca vacca
non devo rifarmi tutto o gesù
devo fare così 8 mila volte ho sbagliato
non volevo cliccare un cliccato mm
venuto come east come spasmo del dito
porca vacca la caga tasta bars solo che
non riuscendo a farla perché sto facendo
cagate di può cliccare col dito
sull'estro perché ho uno spasmo al dito
medio dubstep melanzana ragazzi si
alzerà il volume a palla però visto
direi tutti vino
deve continuare ancora tanto sta facendo
davvero chiedo e non si sa mai
un'ora di leccate d occhio e ragazzi è
così che si limona per chi non l'avesse
mai fatto
senza guardare la gara che player
sapete che se voi adesso dovrei farmi
tutto
basta morì mio dio
che palle
[Musica]
boh io leccato l'occhio un'ora ed è
esploso esplosi è esploso
vabbè a caso ciao nonno posto o leccato
occhi e preso cose schifose per ore è
stato veramente orribile a non è una
schermata credo stiano parlando di fort
knight
e successo a sta impazzendo ha ingoiato
una roba non avevo visto solo leggendo
la chat sorry ha ingoiato un osso ok a
posto quindi è finito lo show tv questo
spegne la tv
signori questa è la ball boy due ore
esatte di gameplay beethoven op art fall
of food sarri pensano i creatori del
gioco vuol bene ragazzi bellissimo
questi sono i volti delle persone che
hanno assunto lsd mi è piaciuto
veramente tanto quindi ragazzi e questo
era risvegliato
[Musica]
cioè se balbo e che sta cantando una
canzone in tutto il paese aveva staccato
la corrente è successo oggi è veramente
un gioco geniale bene mi sono divertito
è stato molto carino molto molto molto
molto molto molto molto carino quindi
finisce così
[Musica]
un po sono triste mi sembra davvero
affezionato a questa è la ball boy
ragazzi era un gameplay che volevo
riportarla un po che non mi ricordavo
più come nostro gioco
ho fatto bene facevo schifo nel senso
che alcune scene facevano schifo nel
senso che erano brutte da digerire
però molto carino di swiss ball boy very
good
[Musica]
bene wathelet
allora ragazzi facciamo così adesso
stacco la live come si cesta cola live
cipe premi per 15 minuti e poi
nell'inizio una nuova dove facciamo tipo
talk facciamo un po di cagate ok lo
stacco perché così almeno tengo bad boy
singolo come video la parte write
ci siamo tra 5 minuti riparto 5 10 più o
meno
partiamo arriviamo fino alle 8 facendo
cose
quindi se voi avete visto il video di
ball boy non c'entrate nulla ora live
spero vi sia piaciuto commento mi piace
come dice comitato descrizione dove ci
si chiede non ci vediamo come sempre a
un prossimo video hanno aspetta non
chiudo io così video ci diamo ad un
prossimo video da ragazzi